ich habe die Tage eine Instagram Story
hochgeladen in der ich euch darum
gebeten habe mir doch bitte mal
Screenshots von eurer bildschirmzeit des
Handys zuzuschicken und die Nachricht
die ich daraufhin am meisten bekommen
habe war warum white Mode
ich hasse den Dark Mode schreib mir
gerne mal in die Kommentare ob ihr euer
Handy auf hell oder dunkel eingestellt
hat aber ich finde sieht so viel schöner
aus darum soll es allerdings nicht gehen
sondern um die Screentime meiner
Zuschauer und das war teilweise echt
sehr verstörend wir starten allerdings
erstmal mit ein paar humanen Beispiel
diese Person z.B ist täglich vier
Stunden und 15 Minuten in der Wattpad
die nächste Person hat eine
bildschirmzeit von 14 Stunden 16
pro Tag auch einfach die ganze Nacht
durch auf tiktok gewesen was neun
Stunden beinhaltet dicker was tun leben
diese Person hat eine bildschirmzeit von
neun Stunden und 34 Minuten und das ist
ziemlich eindeutig verteilt
sitzt du ganz Screen Limit bei tiktok
eingestellt hat wahrscheinlich so gut zu
funktionieren diese Person hat eine
ziemlich gute bildschirmzeit würde ich
sagen und zwar 5 Stunden das ganze Handy
darauf das kann ihn erwischt oder
irgendwie so eingestellt so oder so
hätte ich allerdings erwartet dass auch
sie tiktok in den Top 2 Top 3 mit am
Start hat bei den Apps dieser meisten
nutzt aber nein auf der Eins ist play
HPO max.com also einfach eine verdammte
Website hier finde ich besonders
interessant weil die Person abgesehen
von der bildschirmzeit einfach die Top
drei Plätze ziemlich even verteilt hat
also tiktok WhatsApp gleich viel Zeit
drin im Gegensatz zu dieser Person
die pro Woche fast 24 Stunden nur auf
einer Schüler Klick learn Info Website
verbringen also bin ich zu alt was ist
das alles diese Person hat einfach eine
bildschirmzeit von viereinhalb Stunden
was im Vergleich zu den ganzen anderen
Screenshot wirklich sehr gering ist die
App die sie allerdings am meisten nutzt
ist gardenscapes
ist einfach ein Spiel wo man sich ein
Garten aufbaut bildschirmzeit von 10
Stunden pro Tag ich habe keine Ahnung
was bei dir falsch läuft ich dachte ich
wäre mit sieben Stunden schon richtig
krank unterwegs aber wir müssen
überlegen dass das noch mein Beruf ist
also zehn Stunden ist brutal aber was
noch brutaler ist ist dass die meiste
Zeit in snapchat verbracht wurde
snapchat ist doch keine App wie insta
Youtuber oder tiktor in der man chillt
sondern man antwortet doch eigentlich
einfach nur nächste Screenshot fand ich
auch sehr interessant denn es ist
erstmal Android ich wusste gar nicht
dass Android sowas hatte ich ich nutze
halt iPhone und fast alles Screenshots
von Euch sind auch vom iPhone aber die
App die sie mit am meisten benutzt
einfach Minecraft
ziehen einhalb Stunden pro Woche in der
Minecraft App
generell sind Games krass vertreten auch
hier top eins klar Instagram soziales
Netzwerk aber zwei supremise die 1914
und lsw-sager also auch englisch
es ist schon sehr verrückt die
unterschiedlich das ist und das ist auch
sehr sehr crazy was diese bildschirmzeit
Funktion für einen Mehrwert bietet du
kannst halt vor real einfach ganz genau
tracken in welcher App du wie lange
warst kannst dann Limits einstellen
kannst eine Sucht die ist ja wirklich
wie alle sind Smartphones süchtig die
anderen mehr die anderen weniger kannst
es dann quasi im ersten Schritt schon so
ein bisschen selber dich regulieren und
das Zurückstellen das ist schon sehr
sehr cool das bräuchte vielleicht dann
auch mal diese Person
121 Stunden also sie ist pro Tag
wirklich die ganze Zeit am Handy
vielleicht ist es einfach dauerhaft an
hängt an der Wand haben ja einige reiche
Leute so ein iPad irgendwie an der Wand
oder sowas diese Person hat eine
bildschirmzeit von 5 Stunden 45 was an
sich jetzt erstmal nichts krass
erwähnenswertes ist allerdings nutzt sie
die meiste Zeit in der App Twitter
ich
habe halt damals gedacht als es
übernommen wurde von Elon Musk das ist
halt so voll krass wird und so wieder
voll im Trend kommt aber twitter ist
doch wirklich ist auch tot in
Deutschland oder sie hat eine
durchschnittliche bildschirmzeit von 10
Stunden 17 was wirklich enorm ist ihr
seht auch anhand dieser Farben da ne
dunkelblaue soziale Netze hellblaue
Spiele und Orange sonstiges das was sie
allerdings wirklich am meisten nutzt ist
tiktok
und das fand ich sehr sehr interessant
das wirklich die meisten
tiktok in den Top 3 haben
es ist so brutal wie diese App einen in
ihren Band sieht ihr könnt mir auch
gerne folgen Laser diese Person hat eine
bildschirmzeit von 18 Stunden 7 was
wirklich sehr sehr krass ist die
verteilt sich allerdings auf diese
Uhrzeiten
also von 0 bis 11 Uhr ist die ganze Zeit
Produktivität und zwar fantastical 2
also Kalendereintrag wahrscheinlich ist
es einfach Ihr Laptop weil der
Screenshot war auch ein bisschenuviert
und der ist irgendwie über Nacht
angeblieben oder so machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten bildschirmzeit
Screenshots und zwar diesem hier 7
Stunden 45 ganz entspannt das Screenshot
man sieht doch hier das die meiste Zeit
die Person wirklich so 22 23 24 Uhr am
Handy war einfach kurz vorm
Schlafengehen und sie war die meiste
Zeit in homescapes
also diese ganzen Strategie Aufbauspiele
sind sehr sehr verbreitet hier wieder
ein Android Screenshot und die Person
hat auf der 1 einfach FIFA mobile
also das FIFA Spiel auf dem Handy oder
auf der zwei einfach die Galerie
pro Woche fast 5 Stunden nur in den
eigenen Fotos unterwegs das ist der
nächste Screenshot und zwar 6 Stunden 21
was an sich relativ einfach Durchschnitt
ist bei den ganzen Screenshots die ihr
mir zugeschickt habt allerdings ist auch
hier wieder tiktok extrem stark auf der
Eins und wir sehen dass hier ein Limit
gesetzt wurde sogar von 30 Minuten für
tiktok und Instagram das wird überhaupt
nicht eingehalten sie ist bei 16 Stunden
bei tiktok also wenn ihr euch diese
Limit setzt dann sollte die vielleicht
auch ein bisschen einhalten diese Person
hat einen Tagesdurchschnitt von fast 12
Stunden was extrem viel ist allerdings
noch 50%
weniger im Vergleich zur Vorwoche also
davor hatte die Person einfach 24
Stunden bildschirmzeit am Tag
sag mal schläfst du auch das lustige an
diesem Screenshot ist allerdings dass
die meiste Zeit verbracht wurde in der
Einstellungen App
darunter sind nur noch Instagram mit
fünf Minuten und tiktok mit zwei Minuten
aber die Einstellungen mit fast 12
Stunden
ja
gibt halt Dinge einzustellen diese
Person hat eine bildschirmzeit von 9
Stunden 40 und die am häufigsten
verwendete App ist Safari
das finde ich auch sehr interessant es
wäre auch mal sehr sehr cool wenn Apple
oder auch Android das so einführen würde
dass dort nicht dann die App steht
sondern wirklich bei Youtube dann der
Kanal wo man vielleicht am meisten war
bei Safari dann halt die Website diese
Person hat einfach eine Durchschnitts
bildschirmzeit von einer Stunde 56 was
ich extrem bemerkenswert finde
das sind zwei Stunden am Handy pro Tag
wo ich mir früher gedacht hätte wenn ich
zwei Stunden am Tag Gameboy spielen
dürfte es wäre krass
aber mittlerweile ist es einfach so
unfassbar wenn man weniger als fünf
Stunden am Tag am Handy war diese Person
ja deine bildschirmzeit von 9 Stunden 39
durchschnittlich am Tag und am
häufigsten verwendet logischerweise
tiktok aber auch Pokémon go
ich wusste nicht mal dass das noch
wirklich interessant ist oder geschweige
denn existiert diese Person hat eine
bildschirmzeit von 6 Stunden und 5
Minuten und ist einfach auf dem zweiten
Platz mit turnings ready unterwegs
da muss man Holz umdrehen
in einer
App wie kann man da drei Stunden pro
Woche drin verschwenden hier exakt das
gleiche 10 Stunden 6 bildschirmzeit und
einfach Candy crush auf der 2 was Bruder
spätestens nach 10 Minuten würde ich mir
denken ey ich bin so unproduktiv gerade
komm bei Seite ich muss jetzt irgendwie
was machen oder so es ist ja total
schädlich für die Augen und wo wir
gerade schon beim Thema schädlich für
die Augen sind würde ich sagen kommen
auch schon zum letzten bildschirmzeit
Screenshots für heute und zwar diesem
hier 17 Stunden 31 pro Tag
menschlich gesehen ziemlich Abstoß